let's start this video by throwing a
mouse
a dog and an elephant from a skyscraper
onto something soft
let's say a stack of mattresses the
mouse lands and
is stunned for a moment before it shakes
itself off and walks away pretty annoyed
because that's a very rude thing to do
the dog breaks all of its bones and dies
in an unspectacular way
and the elephant explodes into a red
puddle of bones and inside
and has no chance to be annoyed why does
the mouse survive
but the elephant and dog don't the
answer is size
size is the most underappreciated
regulator of living things
size determines everything about our
biology how we're built
how we experience the world how we live
and die
it does so because the physical laws are
different for different sized animals
life spans seven orders of magnitude
from invisible bacteria
to mites ants mice dogs
humans elephants and blue whales
every size lives in its own unique
universe right next to each other
each with its own rules upsides and
downsides
we'll explore these different worlds in
a series of videos
let's get back to the initial question
why did our mouse
survive the fall because of how scaling
size
changes everything a principle that
we'll meet over and over again
very small things for example are
practically immune to falling from great
heights because the smaller you are
the less you care about the effect of
gravity
imagine a theoretical spherical animal
the size of a marble
it has three features its length its
surface area which is covered in skin
and its volume or all the stuff inside
it like organs
muscles hopes and dreams if we make it
10 times
longer say the size of a basketball the
rest of its features don't just grow
10 times its skin will grow 100 times
and its insides or its volume grows by 1
000 times
the volume determines the weight or more
accurately
mass of the animal the more mass you
have
the higher your kinetic energy before
you hit the ground and the stronger the
impact shock
the more surface area in relation to
your volume or mass you have
the more the impact gets distributed and
softened and also the more air
resistance will slow you down
an elephant is so big that it has
extremely little surface area in ratio
to its volume
so a lot of kinetic energy gets
distributed over a small space
and the air doesn't slow it down much at
all that's why it's completely destroyed
in an impressive explosion of goo when
it hits the ground
the other extreme insects have a huge
surface area in relation to their tiny
mass
so you can literally throw an ant from
an aeroplane and it will not be
seriously harmed
but while falling is irrelevant in the
small world there are other forces that
are harmless for us
but extremely dangerous for small beings
like surface tension which turns water
into a potentially deadly substance for
insects
how does it work water has the tendency
to stick to itself
its molecules are attracted to each
other through a force called cohesion
which creates a tension on its surface
that you can imagine as a sort of
invisible skin
for us this skin is so weak that we
don't even notice it normally
if you get wet about 800 grams of water
or about one percent of your body weight
sticks to you
a wet mouse has about three grams of
water sticking to it
which is more than ten percent of its
body weight
imagine having eight full water bottles
sticking to you when you leave the
shower
but for an insect the force of water's
surface tension is so strong
that getting wet is a question of life
and death
if we were to shrink you to the size of
an ant and you touch water
it would be like you were reaching into
glue it would quickly engulf you
its surface tension too hard for you to
break and you drown
so insects evolve to be water repellent
for one their exoskeleton is covered
with a thin layer of wax just like a car
this makes their surface at least partly
water repellent because it can't stick
to it very well
many insects are also covered with tiny
hairs that serve as a barrier
they vastly increase their surface area
and prevent the droplets from touching
their exoskeleton
and make it easier to get rid of
droplets to make use of surface tension
evolution cracked nanotechnology
billions of years before
us some insects have evolved a surface
covered by a short
and extremely dense coat of water
repelling hair
some have more than a million hairs per
square millimeter
when the insect dives underwater air
stays inside their fur
and forms a coat of air water can't
enter because the hairs are too tiny to
break its surface tension
but it gets even better as the oxygen of
the air bubble runs out
new oxygen diffuses into the bubble from
the water around it while the carbon
dioxide diffuses outwards into the water
and so the insect carries its own
outside lung around
and can basically breathe underwater
thanks to surface tension
this is the same principle that enables
pond skaters to walk on water by the way
tiny anti-water hairs the smaller you
get the weirder the environment becomes
at some point even air becomes more and
more solid
let's now zoom down to the smallest
insects known about half the size of a
grain of salt
only 0.15 millimeters long the fairy fly
they live in a world even weirder than
other insects
for them air itself is like thin jello a
syrup-like mass surrounding them at all
times
movement through it is not easy flying
on this level
is not like elegant gliding they have to
kind of grab and hold onto air
so their wings look like big hairy arms
rather than proper insect wings
they literally swim through the air like
a tiny gross alien through syrup
things only become stranger from here on
as we explore more universes of
different sizes
the physical rules are so different for
each size that evolution had to engineer
around them
over and over as life grew in size in
the last billion years
so why are there no ants the size of
horses
why no elephants the size of amoeba why
we'll discuss this in the next part
we have a monthly newsletter now sign up
if you don't want to miss
new videos and for bonus videos
[Music]
you